in a most excellent turn of events Orion
Pictures has finally dropped the first
teaser trailer for what sure to be the
single greatest cinematic endeavor in
the history of humankind Bill and Ted
faced some music the long-awaited
continuation of the adventures of Keanu
Reeves Ted Theodore Logan and bill S
Preston Esquire played by Alex
winter-hardy on dudes it's been a long
time since we last saw our righteous
heroes we first met them in 1988 Bill &
Ted's Excellent Adventure in which the
pair travelled through time to collect
historical figures put a final high
score report and discovered their
destiny for the band's the wild
stallions to unite the world through
music then in 1991 we went along for
Bill & Ted's bogus journey which Sora
heroes killed by evil robot versions of
themselves from the future they
descended to hell and were forced to
escape by winning a terrifying and tense
game of Twister against William Sadler's
death Bill and Ted face the music we'll
find the two in middle age somehow
having failed for all this time to write
the song that will save humanity there's
a panel of radical dudes and dudettes
from the future who are none too pleased
sir Bill & Ted's failure there's a
return of the famous telephone booth and
the circuits of time and there's one
bright idea by Ted to go to the future
and steal the world savings song from
themselves after all stealing if we're
stealing it from ourselves fans should
be overjoyed that this trailer is
finally here and the movie looks every
bit as hilarious and awesome as we
thought it would with all of that
excellence flying at your face though
there are a few small details you might
have missed after an extremely brief
shot of what appears to be a hologram of
the earth indicating some kind of
phenomenon occurring in Southern
California we see Bill and Ted in the
phone booth intercut with a scene in
which Ted cooks up their plan to travel
to the future but in one very
interesting sequence two things are
shown in quick succession bill and Ted
wearing tuxedos giving some kind of
speech that's what could only be a
wedding and a shot of their daughters
Billy Little Bill Logan played by
Bridget Lundy pain and Thea little ted
preston
who's portrayed by samara weaving that's
right villains had named their daughters
after each other
in case you forgotten we've met them
once before
this is little bill we don't see the
duo's wives the princesses and this
trailer for Bill and Ted face the music
but we know they'll figure into the
story
please Jayma Mays has portraying Bill's
wife Joanna and Children's Hospital Erin
Hayes will play Ted's wife Elizabeth
still it certainly looks like one or
both of Bill and Ted's daughters will be
getting hitched and if you know Bill and
Ted then you know that there are no
unimportant plot points perhaps it's
these nuptials that will finally move
the guys to write their world-saving
tune perhaps I'll have to keep circling
around in time to give a dozen versions
of this speech until they get it right
for some reason there's a lot that could
be going on here
but it seems significant that this shot
was included in the trailer another
significant shot this one yep but that's
william sadler reprising his role as
death rocking out with his excellent
friends in Bill and Ted's bogus journey
death was eventually brought around to
the side of righteousness joining the
wild stallions and accompanying Bill and
Ted on the journey to superstardom in
another shops we can see that at one
point the guys were indeed pretty
successful with their music there's a
professionally made wild stallions
leather jacket framed on the wall in
another frame you can spot what
certainly looks like an issue of rolling
stone with our heroes on the cover there
are other magazine and newspaper
clippings on the wall like the one seen
drawing bogus journeys closing credits
of course all of those clippings told us
the story that Bill and Ted had
basically succeeded in achieving world
peace so what could have happened to
disrupt the timeline perhaps death will
have some knowledge of the situation to
impart and now about that sojourn to a
possible future or perhaps an alternate
reality
apparently in one attempt to steal their
world savings song from themselves bill
instead end up snagging one iteration of
the tune from ultra jag to prison bound
versions of themselves
how'd you like our song it's a little on
the dark side but you know that's cool
it's unclear what these lunkheads did to
get themselves thrown in prison but
judging by their tattoos it appears that
they hadn't lived radically different
from their regular counterparts
prior to Breaking Bad bill had a wild
stallions tattoo and Ted has one reading
Elizabeth and Billy forever the names of
his wife and daughter
it looks like Bill and Ted may have to
encounter a bunch of different versions
of themselves while attempting to hunt
down the song that will save the world
we could only guess as to what other
kind of bills and Ted's might be out
there in the multiverse and we certainly
have every hope that Bill and Ted face
of music will show us when it arrives in
theaters on August 21st check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the bail so you don't miss a single one
[Music]